Merhaba güzel arkadaşım. Kimyanın
Kimyası kanalına tekrardan hoş geldin.
Nasılsın? Umarım iyisindir. Bugün
seninle sıvıların genel özelliklerine
şöyle bir giriş yapacağız. Bu girişten
sonra buharlaşma nedir? Yoğuşma nedir?
Buharlaşma hızı nedir? Hatta bu hıza
etki eden faktörler nelerdir? Bunların
üzerinde duracağız. Videonun sonunda
birkaç tane küçük alıştırma yapacağız.
Bu videoyu sonlandıracağız. Bir sonraki
videoda karşına denge buhar basıncı,
buhar basıncı gibi kavramlar gelecek.
Önemli olduğu için ve bu videonun uzun
sürmemesini istediğim için o konuyu ayrı
bir video olarak çekeceğim. O yüzden
takipte kalmaya devam et. Haydi gel
başlayalım. Sıvıların genel
özelliklerine geldiğimizde senin ta
ortaokuldan aşina olduğun bilgiler
karşına çıkacak. Katı tanecikler
üzerinden yürümeye başlayalım. Şimdi
biliyorsun ki katılar maddenin en
düzenli haliydi. Neden? Tanecikler
birbirine çok yakın, çok sık bir şekilde
istiflendikleri için. Maddenin en
düzensiz hali de gazlardı. Çünkü gaz
tanecikleri nerede oldukları belli
olmayan serseri mayınlar gibi
aralarındaki boşluk çok fazla olacak
şekilde istifleniyorlardı. Hatta
istiflenmek kelimesini kullanmak hiç
doğru olmaz. Bunların enerjileri çok
yüksek olduğu için nerede oldukları
belli değildi. Gazları işlerken
göreceğiz. Sıvılara geldiğimizde ise
sıvılar katılarla gazların tam ara
noktasında. Yani tanecikleri ne çok sık
istifleniyor katılar kadar ne de gazlar
kadar çok başı boş hareket ediyor. Yani
sıvılarda da aslında bir düzenlilik söz
konusu. Senin bu sıvı taneciklerinin
arasındaki boşluk evet katılara göre bir
tık daha fazla ama hala daha çok az
gazlara göre. Bundan dolayı da bu sıvı
taneciklerinin arasındaki uzaklık çok az
olduğu için biz sıvıları
sıkıştıramıyoruz. İkinci bir madde yine
aynı noktaya gelecek. Bu sıvı
taneciklerimin arasındaki boşluklar az
olduğundan dolayı basınc değişmesi gibi
herhangi bir dış faktör senin sıvının
hacmini çok da fazla değiştirmeyecek.
Neden? Çünkü tanecikler arasındaki
boşluk çok az. Tanecikler arasındaki
boşluklar ne kadar fazla olursa aynı
gazlardaki gibi dış basınçlar, dış
faktörler maddeyi o kadar etkiliyor.
Bunu aklından çıkarmak. Ve size
ortaokulda sürekli öğrettiler. Dediler
ki sıvılar bulundukları kabın şeklini
alabiliyorlar. Yanlış arkadaşlar.
Sıvılar bulundukları kabın
doldurabildikleri kadarının şeklini
alabilirler. Koskocaman bir kap düşün.
Sen o kaba 100 milim bir su
dolduruyorsun. Su koyuyorsun. E senin o
ilave ettiğin su kabın aslında sadece
dibinin şeklini almıyor mu? O yüzden biz
diyoruz ki sıvılar bulundukları kabın
doldurabildiklerinin kadar şeklini
alırlar. Yine en başta söylediğimiz gibi
sıvı taneciklerinin arasındaki boşluklar
katı hale göre çok, gaz haline göre ise
oldukça azdır. Ne dedik? Katı ile gaz
arasında bir yerde geziniyor dedik.
Senin sıvılarının belirli hacimleri
vardır ve arkadaşlar sıvıların
birbirleri içerisinde yayılma özelliği
vardır. Buna verebileceğimiz en güzel
örnek mürekkebin suda yayılmasıdır.
Fakat şöyle bir nokta var. Senin sıvı
taneciklerinin arasındaki boşluklar gaz
taneciklerinin arasındaki boşluklara
göre daha az olduğu için sıvıların
yayılmaları gazların yayılmalarına göre
çok daha yavaş gerçekleşiyor. Şimdi
geldik buharlaşma ve yoğunlaşma ya da
diğer bir adıyla yoğuşma olayına. Fakat
bunları öğrenmeden önce senden bilmeni
istediğim çok önemli bir bilgi var.
Bizim buharlaşma olayımız yalnızca ve
yalnızca sıvının yüzeyinde
gerçekleşiyor. Güzel arkadaşım. Bazı
arkadaşlarımız bunu kaynamayla
karıştırabiliyor. Kaynama olayı sıvının
her yerinde, her bir noktasında
gerçekleşirken buharlaşma dediğimiz olay
yalnızca sıvının yüzeyinde
gerçekleşiyor. Bunu cebe attıktan sonra
artık buharlaşma neymiş? Bence bunu
öğrenebiliriz. Güzel arkadaşım, benim
buharlaşma dediğim şey şu. Sen
biliyorsun ki buharlaşma sıvının
yüzeyinde gerçekleşiyor. İşte sıvının
yüzeyinde bulunan bu
taneciklerden moleküllerarası çekim
kuvvetlerini yenebilecek düzeye ulaşmış
olan taneciklerin yani kinetik enerjisi
artmış olan taneciklerin artık sıvı
yüzeyini terk ederek sıvı fazdan buhar
veya gaz fazına geçmesine buharlaşma
diyorum. Yandaki görsel bunu çok güzel
anlatıyor. Farkındaysan içi dolu bir kap
su var. Bu kabın içerisinde pembe
taneciklerin var. Bak bunlar hala
sıvının içerisinde farkındaysan. Demek
ki bunlar hala moleküller arası çekim
kuvvetlerini yenebilecek, o bağları
kırabilecek kinetik enerjiye ulaşamamış.
Dolayısıyla senin bu pembe taneciklerin
buharlaşmaya uğrayamıyor. Fakat sıvının
yüzeyine baktığımda yukarıya doğru kopup
giden beyaz tanecikleri görüyorum. Sen
de görüyor musun? İşte senin bu
taneciklerin artık belirli bir kinetik
enerjiye ulaşmış. Diğer taneciklerden
çok daha yüksek enerjili. Ne yapmak
istiyor? kendini yukarıya yukarıya sağa
sola fırlatmak istiyor. Artık sıvı
halden uzaklaşıp gaz hali buhar haline
geçmek istiyor. Bak görselde de sana
zaten bunu açıklamış. demiş ki,
"Ortalama kinetik enerjisi yüksek olan
moleküller yüzey gerilimini yenerek
buharlaşır." Yüzey gerilimi dediğimiz
olay aslında moleküller arası çekim
kuvvetinin oldukça yüksek olduğu bir
yerdir. İşte bundan çıkmayı başarabilen,
bundan kurtulmayı başarabilen bir
tanecin enerjisinin çok yüksek olması
lazım. O enerjiye ulaşan taneciklerim
artık sıvının yüzeyinden hop kopup
gidiyor. Sıvı halden gaz hale geçmiş
oluyor. Şimdi benim için çok önemli olan
bir yere geçiyorum. İyi odaklan. Bizim
kimyada iki adet tepkime türümüz var
arkadaşlar. Bunlardan birisi endotermik,
diğeri egzotermik tepkimeler. Bahsetmiş
olduğumuz buharlaşma olayı endotermik
bir tepkimedir. Peki hocam endotermik
nedir? Egzotermik nedir? Endotermik
tepkimeler şudur arkadaşlar. Tepkimenin
yürüyebilmesi için her zaman dışarıdan
ısı alması lazım. Her zaman dışarıdan
enerji alması lazım. Tepkime
gerçekleşirken her zaman dışarıdan ısı
ve enerji alıyorsan bu tarz tepkimelere
biz endotermik tepkimeler diyoruz. Bir
de egzotermik tepkimelerimiz var. Burada
egzozdan, arabanın egzozundan aklına
gelsin. Her zaman artık dışarıya ısı
enerji veriyorlar. Arabanın egzozları da
aynen böyle değil midir? Araba
çalıştıkça çalıştıkça dışarıya bir duman
atar, bir enerji atar, bir sıcaklık
atar. O yüzden egzotermik dediğimde
arabanın egzozu aklına gelsin. Ne
yapıyoruz? Dışarıya sürekli ısı
veriyoruz, enerji veriyoruz. Anlaştık
mı? Peki bu bilgiler senin için neden
önemli? Biliyorsun ki buharlaşma
dediğimiz şey aslında sıvı halden gaz
hale geçiştir. Sen ortaokuldan
biliyorsun ki maddenin en düzensiz hali
gaz tanecikleriydi. Gaz taneciklerinin
bu kadar düzensiz olmasının sebebi
onların enerjilerinin çok yüksek
olmalarından kaynaklanıyordu. O zaman
bana sen şunu söyle. Sıvı taneciklerimin
enerjileri gaz taneciklerime göre daha
düşük olmaz mı? enerjisi daha düşük.
Yazayım şuraya. Sıvı taneciklerim gaz
taneciklere göre daha düzenli oldukları
için bunların enerjileri gazlara göre
daha düşük. Gazlar sıvılara göre daha
düzensiz oldukları için gazların
enerjileri sıvılara göre çok daha
yüksek. Şimdi sen buharlaşma olayını
gerçekleştiriyorsun. Bu buharlaşma
olayını gerçekleştirirken sıvı halden
gaz haline geçeceksin. Yani enerjisi
düşük bir konumdan enerjisi çok yüksek
bir konuma geçmek istiyorsun. Senin o
zaman bünyeni dışarıdan enerji alman
gerekmiyor mu? Tabii ki de gerekiyor.
İşte bu yüzden biz diyoruz ki buharlaşma
olayı endotermik bir tepkimedir. Yani
sürekli dışarıdan ısı alacak ki kendi
bünyesinde var olan şu düşük enerjiyi ne
yapacak? Sürekli yükseğe taşıyabilecek.
Yoğuşma olayına gelelim. Yoğuşma olayı
da aslında buharlaşmanın tam tersi. Yani
maddenin gaz veya buhar fazından sıvı
faza geçmesine ben yoğuşma, yoğunlaşma
diyorum. Benim bu yoğuşma, yoğunlaşma
olayım ısı vererek gerçekleşen yani
egzotermik bir tepkimedir. Neden biliyor
musun? Az önce konuştuk. Ne dedik?
Gazların enerjisi çok yüksek. Sıvıların
enerjisi gazlara göre daha düşük. Hemen
yazıyorum. E şimdi mantıklı düşün. Sen
enerjisi çok yüksek bir
konumdayken enerjisi daha düşük bir
konuma geçiş yapmak istiyorsun. O zaman
bünyendeki fazla enerjiyi ne yapacaksın
güzel arkadaşım? Sürekli dışarıya vermek
zorunda kalacaksın. Bu yüzden biz
diyoruz ki yoğuşma, yoğunlaşma olayları
egzotermiktir. Yani sürekli dışarıya
enerji verir, ısı verir. Neden? Çünkü
sen enerjisi çok yüksek bir halden artık
enerjisi daha düşük olan bir hale doğru
hareket ediyorsun. Bu arada bilmiyorum
farkında mısınız? Hala sesimde bir
cızırtı, bir kalınlık, bir detonolik var
arkadaşlar. İşte bunun sebebi size
ikinci dönem 1inci yazılı
hazırlayamamışın hazırlayamamış olmamın
sebebi çok ağır bir domuz gribi
geçirdim. Hala daha sesim kendi yerine
gelmedi. Vücut olarak da hala tam olarak
toparlayabilmiş değilim ama işte
buradayız. Sizinleyiz. Aman diyeyim siz
de kendinize dikkat edin. Havalar bir
ısınıyor bir soğuyor. Kamu spotumuzu
gerçekleştirdikten sonra konumuza geri
dönüyoruz. Hız kavramı. Hız kavramını
sen bak tam olarak bahsettiğim olay bu.
Nasıl detone oldum? Gördün mü? Hııza
geri dönüyorum. Hız kavramını sen nasıl
ifade edersin? Hız dediğimiz şey nedir?
Şöyle düşün. Liseyi bitirmişsin.
Üniversiteni okumuşsun. Mezun olmuşsun.
Güzel bir işte çalışıyorsun ve paranı
kazanıp altına arabanı çekmişsin.
Otobanda 90
km/sat hızla arabanda ilerliyorsun. Sen
fizikten biliyorsun ki bu 90 km/sat
aslında senin için bir hız kavramı.
Neden? Çünkü bu ifade sana diyor ki sen
bir saatte 90 kmrlik yer
değiştiriyorsun. 90 kmlik yol alıyorsun
diyor. O zaman bizim hız dediğimiz şey
şu değil midir? Birim zamanda
gerçekleşen değişimi ifade etmek için
kullandığımız kavrama bir biz hız
diyoruz. Fakat bu hızlarımızın birimleri
değişebilir. Şöyle düşün. Doğal gazın
yanması mikrosaniyede gerçekleşen bir
olay. Şu an buradaki birimin
mikrosaniye. Demirin paslanması,
oksitlenmesi, yanması aylar süren bir
olay. Burada birim saniyen aylar artık 3
ay, 5 ay ne kadar olduğunu sen söyle
bana. Elmasın oluşması veya petrolün
oluşması ise yüzy yıllar süren bir olay.
Çok çok uzun süren bir olay. Artık senin
buradaki birimin ise yüzyıllar.
Farkındaysan bu hızları ifade etmek için
kullandığımız birimler sürekli değişime
uğrayabiliyor. Buharlaşma hızı dediğimiz
şey ise artık birim zamanda buharlaşan
sıvı miktarına yani sıvı halden gaz hale
geçen molekül sayısına biz buharlaşma
hızı diyoruz. Ve buharlaşma hızımızı
etkileyen belli başlı etmenler var.
Bunlardan birincisi sıcaklık. Sen
sıcaklığı ne kadar çok arttırırsan
buharlaşma hızını o kadar çok
arttırırsın. Çünkü sıcaklığı arttırdıkça
taneciklerin kinetik enerjisini
arttıracaksın. Taneciklerin kinetik
enerjisi arttıkça hızları artacak.
Hızları arttıkça da sıvı yüzeyinden
ayrılmaları çok daha kolaylaşacak. Bir
diğer maddemiz sıvının yüzey alanı
genişletilirse buharlaşma hızı artar.
Neden? Sana şöyle açıklamak istiyorum.
Elimde yüzey alanı S olan bir kap olsun.
Bir de elimde yüzey alanı 2S kadar olan
bir kap olsun. Bu kaplara sıvımızı
dolduralım. S'e de doldurdum. 2S'e de
doldurdum. Şimdi yüzey alanı S olan
kabımın birim alanı şurası değil mi? Ve
burada birim alanda kadar tanecik
bulunuyor. Yani şu kadar sıvı
tanecikleri bulunuyor. Bu kadar bulunan
sıvı tanecikleri şuraya bir turuncu alev
çizelim. sıcaklıkla temas ediyor. Yüzey
alanı S olduğu için bu kadar tanecik
sıcaklıkla temas ediyor. Aynı alevi
şuraya da verelim. Buraya da bir
sıcaklık verdim farkındaysan. Buranın da
yüzey alanı 2S. Hatırla biz az önce ne
dedik? Sıvılar bulundukları kabın
doldurabildikleri kadar şeklini alırlar
dedik. O zaman bunun da yüzey alanında
aslında 2S'le paralel olacak kadar sıvı
taneciği var. Farkındaysan buradaki
yüzey alanım daha çok büyüdüğü için
sıcaklıkla temas eden tanecik sayım
artmış oldu. E dolayısıyla sıcaklıkla
temas eden tanecik sayı ne kadar çok
olursa senin de buharlaşma hızın o kadar
hızlı gerçekleşir. Bir diğer maddemiz
dış basınç. Dış basıncı da sana şöyle
açıklamak istiyorum. Öncelikle bir
şuradan yola çıkalım. Basınç dediğimiz
şey biliyorsun ki birim alana uygulanan
dik kuvvette. Şimdi senin buharlaşma
dediğin olay ise sıvının yüzeyinde
bulunan taneciklerin artık sıvı halden
gaz ya da buhar hale geçmesiydi. Yani
farkındaysan yukarı dön yukarı yönlü bir
hareket mevzu bahis. Şimdi mantıklı
düşünelim. Basınç dediğimiz şey birim
alana uygulanan dik kuvvet. Bak, dik
kuvvetlerimi indirmeye başladım. Pembe
pembe. Mantıklı düşün. Birim alana
uygulanan bu dik kuvvetlerimin sayısı
arttıkça senin şu sıvının yüzeyinde
bulunan taneciklerin ne yapacak? Daha
zor bir şekilde yukarıya çıkmayacak mı?
Çünkü sen onlara basınç uygulayarak
aslında bir kuvvet uyguluyorsun. Onları
zor durumda bırakıyorsun. Dolayısıyla
biz diyoruz ki dış basınç arttıkça
buharlaşma hızı azalır. Dış basınç
azaldıkça buharlaşma hızı artar. Çünkü
sıvının yüzeyine uygulanan dik kuvveti
azaltmış oluyorsun. Bundan kaynaklı
olarak da sıvının yüzeyinde bulunan
tanecikler daha rahat bir şekilde yukarı
yönlü buharlaşmaya uğrayabiliyorlar.
Yani dış basıncımız azaltılırsa
buharlaşma hızımız artıyor. Bir de son
bir maddemiz var. Diyoruz ki moleküller
arası çekim kuvveti azaltılırsa
buharlaşma hızı artar. Şöyle düşün.
tanecikler birbirine ne kadar çok yakın
istiflenirse senin moleküller arası
çekim kuvvetin o kadar fazladır ve
dolayısıyla bunların birbirinden
uzaklaşması o kadar zordur. E buharlaşma
olayında biliyorsun ki sıvı tanecikler
birbirlerinden uzaklaşarak artık sıvı
yüzeyini terk edip sıvı ya da gaz hale
geçiyor. Dolayısıyla senin buradaki
moleküller arası çekim kuvvetin ne kadar
çok azaltılırsa yani taneciklerinin
arasındaki boşluklar ne kadar çok
açılırsa buharlaşma hızın o kadar çok
artmış oluyor. Hemen şuna da bir tik
koyalım. Yani güzel arkadaşım moleküller
arası çekim kuvveti dediğimiz zaman
senin aklına sıvı türü gelecek ve sen
biliyorsun ki moleküller arası çekim
kuvveti azaltılırsa buharlaşma hızı
artar. Moleküller arası çekim kuvveti
arttıkça da buharlaşma hızı azalır. Bir
diğer önemli maddemiz ise sıvıda
çözünmüş uçucu olmayan katı madde oranı
arttıkça buharlaşma hızı azalır. Hocam
neden? Bak şimdi elimde iki tane kap
olsun. Şu birinci kabımızda yalnızca saf
su olsun güzel arkadaşım. İkinci
kabımızda ise tuzlu suyumuz olsun.
Biliyorsun ki yemek tuzumuzun formülü
sodyum klorürde iyonik bileşikler
videosundan hatırla. Şimdi bu saf su
olan kabımızda su moleküllerini şöyle
kare kare gösteriyorum ben sana. Burada
sadece saf su bulunduğu için otomatik
olarak sadece neler bulunacak? Su
molekülü tanecikleri bulunacak. Fakat
yandaki kaba baktığım zaman artık burada
tuzlu su var. Yani hem su molekülünün
tanecikleri var. onları hala katı halde
yazma kare kare şekliyle yazmaya devam
ediyorum. Hem de artık sodyum klorür
var. Biliyorsun ki iyonik bileşikler
sulu çözeltilerinde iyonlarına
ayrışıyordu ve sen bu sodyum klorürün
sodyum artı ve klor eksi şeklinde
iyonlaştığını biliyorsun. Yani artık
burada su moleküllerine ek olarak bir de
neler var? İyonlar bulunuyor. E mantıklı
düşün. Senin şuradaki tanecik oranın mı
daha fazladır? Buradaki tanecik oranın
mı daha fazladır? Tabii ki ikinci
kaptaki tanecik oranın daha fazladır.
Tanecik sayın arttıkça, tanecik oranın
arttıkça moleküller arası çekim kuvveti
artar. Bundan dolayı da buharlaşma hızı
azalır. O yüzden biz diyoruz ki sıvıda
çözünmüş uçucu olmayan katı maddeler tuz
gibi, şeker gibi maddeler çözündükçe
buharlaşma hızı azalır. Neden? Çünkü
tanecik sayısı arttıkça moleküller arası
tanecikler arası çekim kuvveti artıyor.
Bundan dolayı da buharlaşma hızı
azalıyor. Yani sözün özü senin
buharlaşma hızın sıvının türüne bağlı.
Sıvının türünü gördüğün zaman aklına
moleküller arası çekim kuvveti
gelecekti. Yani tanecikler arası çekim
kuvvetleri de diyebiliriz biz buna. Bu
moleküller arası çekim kuvveti arttıkça
senin buharlaşma hızın azalıyor. Bir
diğer maddemiz sıcaklıkta hatırla.
Sıcaklık arttıkça taneciklerin kinetik
enerjileri artıyordu. Enerjileri
arttıkça buharlaşma hızı artıyordu. Bir
diğer maddemiz yüzey alanıydı.
Biliyorsun ki yüzey alanı genişledikçe
buharlaşma hızı artıyordu. Neden? Çünkü
birim alanda daha fazla tanecik olduğu
için sıcaklıkla daha fazla temas
edebiliyorlardı. Bir diğer maddemiz dış
basınçtı. Biliyorsun ne dedik? Basınç
dediğimiz şey birim alana uygulanan dik
kuvvettir. Ne kadar az kuvvet uygularsan
birim alana buharlaşma hızın o kadar
artar dedik. Ve son olarak da safsızlık
dedik. Safsızlık dediğimiz şeyi şu
şekilde ifade ettik. Dedik ki suda
çözülmüş katı madde miktarı arttıkça tuz
gibi, şeker gibi buharlaşma hızı azalır.
Çünkü tanecikler arası yani moleküller
arası çekim kuvveti artıyor demiştik.
Şimdi bizim için önemli bir bilgi daha
var. O da şu. Senin sıvını koyduğun
kabının ağzı açıksa bu kapta buharlaşma
gerçekleşebiliyor. Fakat sıvıyı ağzı
kapalı bir kaba koyduysan buharlaşma
olayı tam anlamıyla gerçekleşemiyor.
Neden biliyor musun? Çünkü bu kapalı
kapta hem buharlaşma hem yoğuşma olayı
beraber gerçekleşiyor ve bunların
hızları eşitlense bile bir yerden sonra
döngü şeklinde tekrar etmeye devam
ediyor. Nasıl aklında tutacaksın?
Annesine, babasına, teyzesine, halasına,
anneannesine, babaannesine yemekte
yardım edenler ekran başına diyelim ki
çorba yapıyorsun. Ezogenin çorbası
yapmış olalım. Ne yapalım? O
mercimekler, pirinçler, bulgurlar suyla
biraz daha bütünleşsin diye çorbanın
kapağını kapattın. Şimdi buharlaşma
olayı burada devam ediyor. Çorbanın
kapağını kapattın. Buharlaşma devam
ediyor. Senin sıvının yüzeyinden
taneciklerin sıvı ya da gaz hale geçmeye
devam ediyor. Bu tanecikler yükseliyor,
yükseliyor, yükseliyor, yükseliyor.
Nereye çarpıyor biliyor musun? İşte
şurada görmüş olduğun tencerenin
kapağına
çarpıyorlar. Olay tam da bu çarpmadan
sonra başlıyor. Az önce konuştuk hatırla
dedik ki sıvıdan gaza geçerken düşük bir
enerjiden yüksek bir enerjiye
geçiyorsun. Bu yüzden buharlaşma olayı
endotermik yani ısı alan yani enerji
alan bir olaydır demiştik. Senin bu
tencere kapağına çarpan taneciklerinde
şöyle bir durum oluyor. Bunlar kapağa
çarptıkları an bünyelerindeki enerjiyi,
fazla enerjiyi kaybediyorlar.
Bünyelerindeki fazla enerjiyi
kaybettikleri için de gaz halden sıvı
hale geçiyorlar. Hatırla yoğuşmayı
anlatırken biz dedik ki yoğuşma olayı
egzotermiktir. Yani dışarıya enerji
veren, ısı veren bir olaydır dedik.
Neden dedik? Çünkü biliyorsun ki gaz
halinin enerjisi çok yüksekti. Sıvı
halinin enerjisi daha düşüktü. Ve sen
enerjisi çok yüksek bir yerden düşük bir
yere geçiyordun gazdan sıvıya geçerken.
O yüzden de gaz sahnecikleri
bünyelerinde var olan fazla enerjiyi
dışarıya veriyorlardı. O yüzden ağzı
kapalı bir kapta hem buharlaşma hem
yoğunlaşma olayı beraber devam ediyor ve
bunlar bir süre sonra döngü halinde
birbirini tekrarlamaya devam ediyor. O
yüzden senin sadece ve tamamen
buharlaşma olayından bahsedebilmen için
kabının ağzının açık olması gerekiyor.
Hadi şimdi gel bu öğrendiklerimizi mini
bir alıştırmayla tekrar edelim. Görselde
sana şekiller verilmiş ve diyor ki
şekillerde yer alan sıvıların tamamen
buharlaşması için geçen süreler saat
ikonlarıyla temsil edilmiştir. Biz
bakalım şimdi rastgele değer biçelim.
Şurada farkındaysan şöyle bir geliş var.
Diyorum ki bu 45 dakika. Buna şöyle bir
geliş var. 15 dakika diyelim. Zaten
hepsini biz 4515 dakika cinsinden
yazabiliriz. Çünkü saat ikonlarında
hepsi birbirinin aynısı gibi görüyorum.
Evet. 1inci soru bana demiş ki şekil 1de
ahan da şurada şekil 1'de özdeş kaplarda
aynı sıcaklıkta ve eşit hacimli iki
farklı saf sıvı bulunuyor. Sıvılarımı
kontrol ediyorum. Biri su biri etanol.
İki farklı saf sıvı var. Gerçekten
kaplardaki sıvıların tamamen
buharlaşması için geçen sürelerin farklı
olmasının nedeni nedir? Moleküller arası
çekim kuvvetleri temelinde açıklayınız.
Güzel arkadaşım. Farkındaysan suyumuz 45
dakikada buharlaşmış. Alkolümüz var,
etanolümüz var. Alkolümüz ise 15
dakikada buharlaşmış. Sen biliyorsun ki
moleküller arası çekim kuvveti arttıkça
buharlaşma hızı azalıyordu. O zaman su
alkole göre daha yavaş buharlaştığı için
suyun tanecikler arası çekim kuvveti
yani moleküller arası çekim kuvveti
alkole göre daha yüksektir. Çünkü daha
yavaş buharlaşmıştır diyeceğiz. 2inci
soruya bakalım. bize diyor ki hangi
kaptaki su daha hızlı
buharlaşmıştır? Kaptaki suların
buharlaşma hızlarının farklı olmasını
nasıl açıklarsınız diyor. Bunu
arkadaşlar çıkmamış ama şekil 2 için
söylüyor. Şekil 2 için düşüneceğiz. Yani
şimdi şekil 2'ye baktığımda ikisinde de
farkındaysan ne var? Bu sefer ikisinde
de su var. Değişen önemli bir nokta var.
Bunun yüzey alanıyla farkındaysan bunun
yüzey alanı birbirinden farklı. Buna S
diyelim. Buna 2S diyelim. Sen
videomuzdan artık biliyorsun ki yüzey
alanı arttıkça buharlaşma hızı artar.
Söylediğimizi kanıtlar nitelikte mi?
Evet, tam da öyle. Şu görsele baktığımda
yüzey alanı arttıkça buharlaşma hızının
arttığını yani buharlaşmanın daha kısa
sürede gerçekleştiğini çok net bir
şekilde görebiliyorum. 3. soruya geldim.
Bana diyor ki şekil 3'teki özdeş
kaplarda farklı sıcaklıklarda ve eşit
hacimde su bulunmaktadır. Hemen şekil
3'e dönüyorum. Bakıyorum ikisinde de su
var. Fakat biri 25 S D iken diğeri 80 S
D. Soru devam ediyor. Diyor ki, "Hangi
kaptaki su daha hızlı buharlaşmıştır?
Kaptaki suların buharlaşma hızlarının
farklı olmasını nasıl açıklarsınız?"
Benim öğrencim biliyor ki sıcaklık
arttıkça buharlaşma hızı artar. Neden?
Çünkü sıcaklık arttıkça taneciklerin
kinetik enerjisi yani hızları artıyor.
Hızları arttıkları için de sıvının
yüzeyinden daha kolay bir şekilde
kopabiliyorlar. Bu da buharlaşma hızını
arttırıyor. Bakalım söylediğimizi
kanıtlar nitelikte mi? Evet tam da öyle.
Şu görsele baktığım zaman 80 S derecede
bulunan suyun 15 dakikada buharlaştığını
görüyorum. Yani buharlaşması suya göre
daha hızlı olmuş. Yani söylediğimiz,
iddia ettiğimiz bilimsel bilginin doğru
olduğunu görüyoruz. Şimdi seninle şurayı
doldurmak istiyorum. Bir kavram haritası
vermiş. Ne arttıkça ne oluyor, ne
azaldıkça ne oluyor diye. Bir şeyler
arttıkça buharlaşma hızı artıyormuş.
Sıcaklık arttıkça, sıcaklık arttıkça
kinetik enerji artıyor. Bundan dolayı da
buharlaşma hızı artıyor. Yine bir şeyler
arttıkça buharlaşma hızı artar demiş.
Sen biliyorsun ki yüzey alanı arttıkça
buharlaşma hızın artıyordu. Şurada demiş
ki artık bir şeyler azaldıkça artık
azalt bir şeyleri ki buharlaşma hızın
öyle artsın demiş. Biliyorsun ki dış
basınç azaldıkça yani birim alana etki
eden dik kuvvet azaldıkça buharlaşmanın
hızı artıyordu. Bir de ne azaldıkça?
Tanecikler arası çekim kuvveti. Onu da
farklı bir renkle yazalım. tanecikler
arası çekim kuvveti azaldıkça buharlaşma
hızı artıyordu. Beni dinlediğin için
sana teşekkür ederim. Detayı fazla ama
basit bir konuyu beraber hallettiğimizi
düşünüyorum. Sonraki videolarda görüşmek
üzere. Kendine iyi bak.